[Music]
well thank you so much for taking some
time today I'm excited to introduce you
to the newest product commercial product
from our studio maybe not the sexiest
product but probably our most important
today if you ask me which is our studio
package manager so we're gonna talk
about today we're gonna talk about how
it's important to organize packages and
one way to do that is with a central
repository which is what package manager
helps you create we'll look at that
we're going to talk about automatic
versioning or how you can make sure that
your results are reproducible and at the
package environment those results depend
on is also reproducible look at how you
can use a tool like package manager
anywhere you're running are whether
that's within the open source IDE and a
batch script somewhere or an AR studio
konnekt now I'm going to spend most of
the time looking at these different ways
you might want to expose packages to
users whether it's all of cran a part of
cran and maybe some local packages or
even pulling packages from get and then
finally we'll briefly discuss how you
can track all that's going on through
some usage metrics before we do that
though I don't want to quickly lament an
alternative talk that I don't have the
chance to give which is you know 10
things that I hate about our packages
and if you've seen this excellent movie
from the 80s you might recognize the
killer quote at the end and I think it
does a good job summarizing how I feel
about packages you know I I love them
but I also hate them a little bit but I
hate the most the way I love them and I
think we can all relate to that you know
as our users our packages are what make
the language so powerful and I think we
love them that's why we're here but they
don't come without their set of
challenges and so I want to quickly
discuss a few of those challenges that
you know maybe you've experienced so the
first one is compiler errors you've ever
tried to install a package especially in
a Linux system and gotten garbage like
this you've had a moment of hate
especially for the XML package man it's
tricky
this is a bit harder you know if you at
least for a compilation error if you and
when you go to install a package it'll
fail and it'll fail in an ugly way but
at least it fails there's other errors
that are a bit more subtle which is when
you go to install a package and the
install succeeds but actually using the
package fails and so this is a
discussion pulled from the AR Lang
package and basically what this poor
user had done is they upgraded Arling
but they did upgrade applier and because
deep liar depends on our lane they got
into a situation where both packages
were technically installed but neither
were usable and so Leonel the very
helpful package maintainer he was kind
of walked the user through this
situation his first comment up there is
what I really want you to focus in on
unfortunately in our there's not a great
mechanism for preventing this type of
problem so it's a problem that you can
find yourself in quite frequently
this was made even worse by the fact
that the user then tried to install the
latest version of deep liar onto their
Windows machine and cran was serving an
out-of-date binary so that the problems
got worse and worse so these are kind of
the tip of the iceberg there are two
things that maybe you've you've
encountered yourself but I want to do a
bit of fear-mongering here which is even
if you're a single data scientist
there's a lot more that can go wrong and
the problem is it can go wrong further
down the road so I wanted to discuss a
few problems that if you have the
problem it's really too late it's kind
of like a smoke detector and a fire you
know if if you're burning in the fire
you probably wish you'd invested in the
smoke detector and there's a similar
issue around package management it's
critical that you think of your strategy
for managing packages before you're in
the fire so what does that fire look
like well three things we've seen time
and time again unfortunately with some
of our customers is that the first one
here is you make a critical decision
based on an analysis and then you're not
able to rerun the analysis because when
you click go on your code you get a
package error and that's a really tough
place to be in and it can be quite hard
to try to figure out what you need to
back out or reinstall or change to get
the analysis to run again the second one
here is maybe a bit more mundane but if
you're an our user today who does all
their work on a desktop and you can
install packages from wherever you want
congratulations you're in a happy spot
you won't be there for long as your
analysis leaves and the organization or
permeates the organization you'll likely
be asked to move your analysis into
other places other servers that might
not have as easy access in there in that
and at that point if you haven't thought
at all about what packages you're using
you're gonna have a hard time working
with IT to get those packages into a
happy spot and then finally even
something as simple as sharing your code
with a colleague but you don't have a
plan for package management now it can
be really hard and you'll end up in a
situation where maybe the new junior our
user you've brought onboard is spending
their first day looking at your session
info output trying to reinstall packages
so none of these things are where we
want to be but the good news is that we
can come up with strategies that'll
prevent these problems from happening in
the first place and so that's what we're
gonna talk about today is one role or
the role that package manager can play
in those types of strategies and so what
package manager allows you to do is
instead of having every our client
install packages from the various places
they live you know in github or on cran
or maybe in your own get to enterprise
server instead of having all of the our
clients install on their own you can
have a central place or your own
repository that organizes collects and
governs what packages are available and
then have your actual our clients
install from there and there are many
ways to create these repositories
there's open source packages like mini
cran and we believe that package manager
provides the great end-to-end solution
for organizations that are interested in
solving this type of problem to maybe
help you wrap your head around this I'm
gonna try an analogy with bad clipart
it's worked for me before and I hope it
works again but I love to cook but I
wouldn't consider myself a professional
I'm kind of a hobbyist and so I
typically you know whatever I have in my
pantry I throw into
hope for the best I use you know my home
kitchen appliances and I look for great
deals at the grocery store and I think
that's maybe similar to when I started
in our you know I had the laptop that
was available to me I had the tools that
were available to me and I installed you
know whatever I needed to try to get the
job done but a professional chef would
never take the approach I take to
cooking if they make their day-to-day
business you know by selling delicious
things to eat and they're probably gonna
upgrade each of these things they're
gonna have a detailed recipe to make
sure they get the same results each time
they're gonna have an industrial kitchen
instead of you know my home kitchen and
maybe most importantly they're gonna
focus and own the supply chain for all
the ingredients that they need and we
think it's important that our users who
are using our day-to-day to think of the
same upgrades so there's a lot of
excellent tools that have been built and
will continue to be built for managing
the project to ensure that you have
reproducible results whether that's
something like packrat or even it's a
great start just using our markdown
document where you're forced to knit it
from end to end every once in a while we
also work with a lot of organizations
who spend quite a bit of time focusing
on that equipment upgrade they you know
spend time thinking about how many CPUs
we'll need how much RAM we'll need
getting a new cluster the latest compute
technology but what separates those
organizations from really exceptional
organizations is the organizations that
also consider the supply chain for data
science and here that's critically
package management so I'm not gonna
claim that our studio package manager
will solve all of the problems that I
discussed at the beginning but it will
help a lot with this supply chain and is
a powerful tool that will put you in a
good place have a strategy that meets
all of the needs and then finally before
we hop into the demo I just want to
mention we've heard this and pretty much
every talk today that this type of
supply chain management is not something
you can do on your own so you're gonna
have to work with a number of different
groups IT ops information security
business users
and we've worked really hard to make
sure that package manager makes life
easy for all those different groups so
that you can go to your IT operations
person who doesn't know how to spell are
and walk them through the process of how
they're gonna set up an environment
that'll make you both successful
so let's actually look at the tool a bit
of context our studio package manager is
an on-premise commercial product so it's
something that you would install and
have for your own you know corporate use
I'm gonna show you a demo server that
we've set up and you're more than
welcome to follow along or poke at this
throughout the conference its demoed on
our street OPM comm I'm gonna start by
looking at maybe the simplest case which
is I just need access to cran packages
so here we're looking at ggplot2 and one
of the things that's really exciting
about package manager is that it knows a
lot about the ggplot2 package it knows
all the dependencies that the package
has it also knows critically about all
the reverse dependencies so packages
that in turn rely on ggplot2 we're
looking at the main kind of the current
version but package manager also gives
access to all the previous versions of
the package as well so that's kind of
that first critical bit is you to ensure
reproducibility you have to have a way
to get all of the older versions of
things and so package manager makes
those available so that you can see them
and install them that's the first level
of versioning that happens at the
package level but we also version
everything that happens on the
repository as well so here we're looking
at a log you know like any organization
we need to take in updates from cran
overtime to get access to new packages
or updates new packages but anytime we
do that we record a transactional
version ID and that ID allows us to
either install packages from this moving
tip the latest and greatest or to
install packages from an older point in
time so how do we do that how do we
actually install packages using this
tool well we've worked really hard to
make sure that our users don't have to
change their behaviors or the tools
they're familiar with so all you have to
do is grab a URL again
you can pick if you want the latest and
greatest this default URL and in our
studio one not - we've added a new user
interface for specifying that repo
option so you just throw the URL in
there and then you can use install that
packages as you normally would if you're
running are on a server your admin can
set this for all users so that right out
of the gates they get the right behavior
but I mentioned those versioned IDs so
you can also as of the latest version of
package manager pick from an older point
in time so it's January I have an
analysis that I created back in July and
I need to recreate the environment for
that analysis well I can kind of time
travel back to the repository as it
existed back in July and install any
packages from that point in time and I'd
like to kind of briefly go on a tangent
here so I'll come off of my pedestal in
just a second but people ask us all the
time how docker relates to
reproducibility and docker is an amazing
tool it allows you to programmatically
specify what your environment should
look like but time and time again and I
fact I'm sure you'll see this in other
conference talks you'll see a docker
file that looks like this where
somewhere there's a line that says run
install packages and it's great that
you're specifying what packages should
be in your environment but the problem
is any time you recompile this docker
image you're subject to get whatever
install that packages gives you so
you're not actually gonna get the same
reproducible environment anytime you
recompile the docker file luckily
there's an easy fix here which is to use
you know one of those technic techniques
for freezing the versions of your
packages and so here we're using that
frozen URL and now we're guaranteed that
any time we build this image we're gonna
get the same exact set of packages in
the same versions of those packages so
that's kind of how you might share all
of cran there are other options as well
so a lot of our customers work in really
specific validated environments and in
those cases you might not want all of
cran accessible you might want only a
part of cran
specifically designed and locked down
for a project so we allow you to easily
create these subsets of cran inside
package manager and so here if we look
at this repository called validated it
basically has two packages at the top
level shiny and then extra boost so we
have a record of each of those packages
being added to the repository and along
for the ride all of their dependencies
were added as well if you wanted to add
another package so say I now you know
want to extend this project to include
plummer
you can use the package manager CLI so
that's what we're looking at here is how
admins would interact with this server
and package manager uses that knowledge
of the dependency tree for a package and
the repository that it lives in to
figure out what other things would need
to change for plumber to be added to
this repository so here you can see some
of the dependencies of plummer are
already present others would need to be
added it uses that same intelligence to
give you a preview of what would happen
if you wanted to update one of the
packages so we've worked really hard to
make sure that if you move forward in
time you're doing so in a consistent way
and so you never end up in that crummy
situation where all the packages will
install but some of them won't work so
that's our and those other packages from
cran that are available in this
repository but if we look back at the
log here there is another layer which is
that we have an internal package so a
package that's not available on Crayon
that we also want to make available to
this project it's called our co internal
and to do that you know we have this
package and get on our git Enterprise
server and all we have to do is tell
package manager about it we can ask it
to give us the commits related to this
package or specific tagged releases and
package manager will turn that git
repository into an R package that then
users can install with installed op
packages so you don't have to worry
about trying to get every AR user in
your organization access to your get
infrastructure it can all go through
this
place you have a lot of visibility there
because it's central and so whether
you're using any of these packages from
get this subset that's locked down for a
project or you're just accessing all or
part of cran because everything's going
through this one place you can see and
get visibility into what's going on so
here we can look at package downloads
over the last 90 days we can see what
packages are popular and we can answer
that pesky legal question which is
what's our risk exposure
so maybe the GPL license so it's a great
benefit of going through a central place
is that you have much better visibility
into what's occurring so to do a quick
summary of what we just looked at we
organized packages in a central
repository we saw the two different
levels of versioning that occur both at
the package level and at the repository
as a whole we saw how you might
integrate package manager with our and
actually use this thing by just calling
install the packages looked at the
different flavors of a repository that
you can create and we briefly saw those
usage metrics when I quickly talk about
what's coming up next if you think
that's the very first thing I hated
about our packages they can be hard to
install and so we're gathering a lot of
information about what underlying system
requirements are necessary for packages
to compile we're gonna make those
available to users through package
manager we also hope later this year to
make Linux binaries available as well so
if you're operating on a linux server
you don't have to incur the cost of
compiling it every time you want to use
the package and finally if you're using
bioconductor
I'd love to talk to you more in the
professionals lounge there's a lot of
ways to use bioconductor the package
manager today we'd also like to hear
from you about how we can make it more
of a first-class citizen in the tool all
the details are gonna be available
online but the better way to learn more
is to swing by the professional lounge
we can talk about things drill into
specific parts of the demo and then
finally before I end you know you might
be sold on package manager or you might
not be and either way is fine with us
but I think it's critical for
all of you to have a conversation about
where packages are coming from and the
projects you're using so to encourage
that type of discussion we're announcing
a challenge here if you go to this URL
at the top you know grab out your phone
and take a picture of the slide your
building saw a package called count
depths it's a really simple package it's
just gonna tell you how many packages
your project uses and you might be
surprised at the number assigned a pie
created had more than a hundred and
twelve package dependencies by the time
he counted all of the other things that
were brought in so that the challenge
part tweet us at our studio with that
number get your colleagues to do it too
and you'll be entered into basically a
raffle to win a year free of package
managers will give you a license for a
year but either way we think it's
critically important for everyone to
have a conversation about you know the
114 packages that you're using where are
they coming from and how you're gonna
ensure that you always get them so that
you know the recipe you're creating is
delicious each and every time so that
swing by the Pro Lounge and I think we
might I have time for a few questions
great Thank You Shawn we do have time
for a couple of questions looks like
we've got some hands up so we'll pass
them out hi do you have any strategy
about dealing with system level
dependencies coming from externally from
the system that its living with yeah
definitely so one of the challenges as I
mentioned with our packages is that in
our package can depend on other our
packages obviously but it also can
depend on system dependencies so the XML
to package requires that you have the
Lib XML UNIX dependency and so the first
challenge there is that our packages are
not required to state what those
dependencies are so there is no database
yet with all that information so the
first thing we're doing is creating that
database of information and then we'll
surface it to users through package
manager so when you go to install a
package it'll tell you what other system
dependencies you'll need hi
so this sought this this whole program
looks really really great with the
package management but for those of us
who say aren't working in industry but
maybe working in academia can't be
spending $1,000 a year on a package
manager what recommendations do you have
will there be a like a reduced free
version of this at some juncture or
would you put your money behind mini
crown so all our studio products are
available for free all of our commercial
products are available for free to
teaching institutions there's some terms
and conditions that apply of course but
our sales team would be happy to walk
through those and they're available at
significantly discounted rates if you're
not teaching but working at an academic
university for the purposes of research
I have two questions for the Linux for
the Linux binaries what platforms do you
intend to support will it be Ubuntu red
Red Hat or others yes so we would love
to hear from you about what platforms
you're using but our initial support
will be for adventure in Red Hat second
question for the package when you
install the packages the package manager
is there any kind of an additional
security around it is there package
vetting above and beyond what our core
does for cran yes that's an excellent
question that we get quite frequently is
how do I guarantee the security of an
our package so that's not a problem that
package manager is tackling to be honest
we would need to be a different company
to event all fourteen thousand packages
securely but one thing we can say is
that if you don't have a central place
in that you're installing packages from
there's no way you'll be able to address
any security concerns that your IT group
might have so one of the recommendations
for instance would be to use the fact
that you have a central repository to as
a place for IT to incorporate what other
other security processes they want to
put in place whether as Mark mention at
the end of his talk scanning the
binaries for viruses
[Music]